gonna congratulate the people who are
going to go out into the community to
try and get people vaccinated
hi Madame nice to see you real pleasure
he's wearing a mask in the car for the
purposes of the doc then he walks up to
the mayor with no mask on and shakes her
hand this is in the middle of social
distancing and masking it's just all
uttered nonsense no I'm not going to be
lining up taking a shot on a vaccination
for something that wasn't clear in the
first place if it allowed thousands of
people like you don't get vaccinated
you're going to let this virus continue
percolate in this country and in this
something like the common flu then right
start talking about paying people to get
vaccinated when you start talking about
incentivizing things to get people
vaccinated there's something else going
on with that y'all campaign is about
fear it's about inciting fearing people
you all attack people with fear that's
what this pandemic is you got it it was
about fear you people push this through